Everything was perfect
just like I imagined.
Please.
I'm afraid we're going
to spoil this dress.
Welcome to your home away from home.
This dwelling was built by architect
Fredric Banner in 1955.
If I had to be stuck in a house
it could be worse than this.
Do you think he's watching us?
Oh, yeah.
I remember reading that
Banner was obsessed with the occult.
His wife disappeared
under mysterious circumstances.
His young son went into foster care.
Eldridge.
What’s the address of the house?
1960 Marione Lane.
I’m in his actual house.
Hello.
I must have gotten the days mixed up.
We have it booked till tomorrow.
I’m Eldridge the owner.
I think I saw someone in this house.
I'm worried.
Just let me know you're okay.
Do you live here?
I used to.
I think I found some human remains.
My father committed multiple murders.
The spirit is able
to escape death.
Must have been hard watching Eldridge
turn into his father.
Help me put an end to him.